it smells like shiducy in here if you
took the dog on more walks we wouldn't
be sitting in his toilet
i walk going to take selfies at runyon
doesn't count brooklyn
[Music]
oh my god what it's christian
he invited us to go to san diego
comic-con he said that marvel movies
give you anxiety
not the ones with chris hemsworth hello
daddy
we'll run a car we'll leave tomorrow
this is gonna be the most epic road trip
ever
it's like our romeo and michelle tucson
here we come moment not low to high high
to low high to low
so one ninth in san diego today feel
free to finish your drinks and i hope
you ladies enjoy san diego so what
you're saying is you don't have passes
and we drove three hours to technically
not go to comic con let's get white girl
wasted
this is all about female empowerment
you're bordering out of control
and i kind of like it
we're huge fans oh i mean what happened
with gino is he still your boyfriend
are you jealous that someone's actually
giving me attention for once instead of
you
no i don't want to say radical
but i do want to say radical
whoa whoa whoa cause the nipple guy
taught you nothing sir i see a lot of
people in the backseat
there's always the fun one oh i'm fun my
face i'm not gonna be able to pop for a
week fun ones always know how to find
the party
what was that and then there's the
responsible one
and the responsible one knows how to get
home
well that's deep yeah now the stories
[Music]
that's my best friend for now
you